hey guys just a quick reminder september
16th through the 18th i'll be in phoenix
arizona
uh more dates are coming go to
ryansickler.com you can check out all
the dates
uh there as they come in this episode of
the honeydew is brought to you by
expressvpn and stamps.com
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler
ryanstickler.com ryan sickler on all the
social media
i can't thank you enough for the support
uh this community is growing and growing
i love
that people are out there laughing and
talking about their trauma
uh make sure you're subscribed you're
getting audio on monday you're getting
video
on tuesday subscribe to that youtube
channel and if you want more episodes
uh subscribe to my patreon the honeydew
with y'all it's only five bucks a month
there's no tiers no nothing if you sign
up for a year you get over a month free
um and i'm just highlighting the low
lights with y'all and y'all have not
disappointed that community continues to
grow and continues to blow me away
the stories that you guys are sending in
are just
something else so if you or someone you
know has that story that absolutely has
to be heard please submit to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully we
get to do a story together
um you guys know i record here at the
santa monica music center
and we're doing a program uh with
at-risk youth called outreach through
the arts it's partnering with the santa
monica police department
working with these kids teaching them
about podcasting cameras in front of the
camera behind the camera graphics
editing everything that goes into a free
podcast
that isn't for you to do we're teaching
these kids now give them some experience
open them up to uh some ideas for maybe
careers in the future
things like that i'm proud of it you're
gonna see more and more of uh
some content out of here with those kids
and i just really want to talk about and
promote it because
i love giving back and thank you to lana
and the santa monica police department
uh make sure you go hit the merch store
get your merch we're fully restocked
everything in there the weight is
minimal now
except for what's going on with the usps
ups wouldn't do you like that shout out
to ups baltimore hub primary one joe
avenue all right you all know what we do
over here we highlight the low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers
this week's guest man one of a crab
feast favorite no doubt
first time here on the do ladies and
gentlemen please welcome jesus trail
y'all welcome to the honeydew hey zeus
what's up baby
we're here man so excited to have you on
dude thank you for having me this is
great
i love the space and it's great to see
you i haven't seen you in so
long it's been a minute dude yes thank
you um
look i know we're gonna have some fun
today so before we dive into your
stories
plug promote everything you'd like
please uh just uh go to the website
jesustrangle.com there's some upcoming
shows
uh they're gonna be posted there pretty
soon
uh check out uh tacos contodo on first
we feast we got some episodes up there
and uh yeah yeah just you know social
media the
the twitter at jesus trejo and then
instagram hex who's traveled number one
that's it really
that's great dude i'm so glad to have
you here i thank you for that
if you haven't heard jesus's uh craft
piece episode it's absolutely
something you should go listen to and
there is a story
uh that's in there because it's it is a
honeydew story no doubt
i want to i i don't i want you to retell
okay
the story of your karate class
yeah man i uh how old were you i was in
high school
okay i was in high school you know young
kid and
you know it's like i i've always been
enamored with you know wrestling and
mma and you know and you're tall now how
big are you now
i'm six foot three i was this height in
high school you know they stopped making
mexicans this big in 86. you know you
know yeah
and uh so so there was like a like a
mutai
gym kickboxing gym in uh long beach
right i grew up on the east side of long
beach and i
wanted to go there and you know my
parents didn't have that kind of money
to
put me in a in a class or a school like
that but man did i want to go there and
eventually
it happened and i i went there and real
deal man real deal dudes in there just
kicking the bag i mean it was just like
all-around badass and the
and the and the master of this uh
of of this gym uh master omri
not only five foot flat i mean
uh but just a total badass um well
respected in the community
um but just was an all-around badass and
he was so kind
um so i signed up for classes and i'm
i'm i'm in there after after squad going
and why are you are you in there because
you're being bullied or is it like
something your parents want you just to
get the hell out why are you in there
i i kind of want to go because i i i
would get bullied a lot
yeah i mean so it's like good exercise
and also got to meet people there i was
like
watching like the real deal guys like
kick the bag so i was like
doing that but also i'm like if i can
just learn to defend myself a little bit
so let me ask you what are you what are
you defending yourself from were you
like the big
kid that everyone wanted to pick on so
they could choose themselves and
and you weren't strong and [ __ ] and
you're like [ __ ] i need to no i cry easy
yeah i mean i that's my super power
emotional too yeah man
and uh just thinking about i don't know
if you guys could hear it in my voice
it's like cracking is like
like it feels like my my high school
bullies are just outside this door right
now
um but i used to get picked on a lot and
it was because i was
a big kid so people like oh he can fight
no i just i just eat a lot
you know that's it and just goofy kid
but i would get picked on i would get
i got jumped i got guns pulled on me
like all kinds of stuff
all because you're this size at a young
age
i i'm an easy target people want to pick
on the big guy
you know it's it's long beach there's
you know people you know
and and in a very different path than i
was in life yeah i mean and it just
it is what it is it's an environment um
you know i i always say this is like i
like i like i know they're not a bad
person like
like when i got guns pulled on me i know
they're not bad people
it was just a bad choice you know and um
you know from getting robbed in a
laundromat is like
you know we're in a laundromat and i got
a gun pulled on me
and i still didn't think the person was
bad it's just a bad choice it's like
i would just slap almost splatter they
thought i had money it's like
thank you so much man like uh
so i've always had this like positive
goofy outlook on life and
i don't know just trouble find you when
you're you know a young kid growing up
in long beach but
so i'm at this gym i'm like this is
gonna help with my confidence and all
kinds of stuff so
i'm in there training that was no good
man i would spar
and man there was this dude in there
construction worker cat long hair
and uh he uh i went in the ring to spar
now we have like the like the pads that
we're supposed
to wear but if you're gonna spar at 25
50 percent
no big deal you know it's like i can see
the kick coming you block
that kind of thing it's you you you
choreograph you know i said
but this dude like right away man he
just
this is a grown dude he was probably
like in his 30s i'm what like
16 17. so he's like just like wham like
oh
like everyone's seen those uh those uh
instagram videos where they're wearing
like the body thing
and the and professional boxers are
taking just hits to the summit
and after like 50 hits are like man that
hurts like the dude was
wailing on me with like i had that but i
wasn't i was just like oh
you know just and uh yeah we just kept
going i'm like oh this is part of the
thing
and i remember one day man i'm in there
sparring
and then dude just roundhouse kicks me
just
blow just hits me in the face in the
face just
i buckle up no it just just you supposed
to be going like 25 50 percent he
got a brilliant idea and was like i know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna surprise him
you don't surprise people in a in in a
spa especially with the kids like he's
just in there for
i'm there for cardio bro
you got an ex-wife yeah you're trying to
work out or some [ __ ] you got life
experience bro
i have none of that i'm i'm i'm here
because
i think it's cool and fun yeah i mean
and uh man he round
house kicks me i buckle man and i
remember
everything just going dark and i would
see like little colors like little like
not fireworks ups and i remember hearing
lips
so it's like in cartoons when people get
knocked out like a cartoon character you
see like the birds going around
i could hear that and also i've seen
cartoons where they have like the little
colors i'm like
whoever animated that you've been
knocked out before yeah you know what it
is because that's
so true i saw that maybe because i think
in cartoons who knows but
i get knocked out i'm out and i come
back
and you know omri's there and um
you know the other you know the other
fighters are there and they're like are
you all right man i can't talk
i can't talk and i'm trying to talk and
nothing
and omri is upset he's yelling at the
guy he's like hey you hurt my students
they don't come back and also it's a kid
and i'm just like i'm trying to talk i'm
trying to talk and i can't do it
and uh you know they're jumping on his
case like the
i forget the main fighter's name uh he's
yeah man it's like like i'm trying to
push words out like the last bit of
toothpaste in a tube where you're just
like
like you're like you're trying to like
get the work from the stomach kid
too and i can't get the word out man
ouch couldn't get out and i'm there with
wrapped hands shirtless
in a kickboxing shorts
and just a chubby kid you know i mean
with shorts and
and um i had my feet wrapped up i was
like
i looked apart but it's like hey man
could you sit up or were you just like
i was noodles bro i was i was like
trying to prop up a noodle just
you know just like a newborn baby trying
to hold them but
they're holding me from the back of the
neck kind of thing hey
it's just not good bro
yeah it's like a newborn baby you know i
was
born again at that point yeah i mean but
so
so now we're there and i could you know
i can hear what's going on and they're
arguing with the guy
and then one of the like the main
fighters was in his face he's like you
want to fight somebody you fight me and
he was like much shorter but
this guy was not somebody you mess with
yeah i mean um
and you know they're going back and
forth now my dad's about to pick me up
i'm like this is about to get real bad i
mean
so i'm trying to like get my voice back
so when you know my dad picks me i was
like
you know let's go home i'm never coming
back again and then i can make up
whatever lie i needed to
to justify me never going there again
and
so my dad picks me up and he's like
laying in the
laying on the horn trying to get me to
come out and i'm you know finally he
gets off and
you know my dad's a gardener he worked
construction during the day
you know mo lawns you know in the
evening so it's like
it's late you know he gets out of the
work truck and he's like hey
come on let's go and then you know you
know they tell him what happened he's
like what so he goes over there and i
can't talk he's like why can't he talk
well and then i didn't remember you
still couldn't talk when your dad showed
up
you couldn't get it out no i couldn't
get it out cause then they parted
they parted the sea of fighters and
people training at the gym it was a
small gym you know
and then they're like you know he kicked
him in the head he's like he did what
you know kind of thing and i was just
like
i couldn't talk i mean i was just like
so how much time would you say has gone
by
now from you getting roundhoused a
lifetime
because a lifetime i don't know what
that is
they say time slows down in a black hole
that's what it felt like
all i could hear is and i still got
birds doing laughs around my my dome you
know
and uh so so my dad's upset
my dad's upset he he's like you know
leaves
and he goes to his uh work truck and he
takes out the rustiest machete you've
ever seen
the rustiest of the and he grabs and
he's outside he's like come outside
and he's sparking his damn machete on
the ground
so you're just here
you still can't talk i can't talk but
like i'm up on my feet i remember being
up on my feet just kind of like
you know just kind of like no no no no
chill out and you know omri's out there
now and listen i've been in la
long enough i've been in california long
enough i know these little gyms
i know the little strip mall it's in i
can't imagine driving by and just
looking over and seeing some dude in the
parking lot just
sparking a machete and being like wonder
what the [ __ ] going on in there you
know
and man he's sparking he's like come out
here my dad's like
five foot yeah i mean little guy heart
of a lion man and he's
he's ready to go i mean i mean i don't
have kids of my own but i can only
imagine where my dad was at that time
it's like yeah
oh we're going we're going the distance
however this ends right
so he's sparking the things coming out
so omri's out there no
you know omri's a you know cambodian man
my dad's a mexican man and they're
trying to communicate with each other
and you know army's like hey man this
you know this dude you know i'm i'm
really sorry
you know um you know kind of think my
dad is not hearing it and the guy's kind
of like hey my bad we were just sparring
kind of thing
and man they didn't get ugly um
i ended up not going back i was just
scared you know i was just scared and
you know i remember some time some time
went back right i
went back some time went by and i'm out
there mowing lungs with my dad
and um and the dude pulls up and uh he's
in
you know he's in the in the in the truck
or whatever
he's like hey i'm like oh [ __ ] you know
there he is
so you know i stop the moor and i go
over there my dad's in the back this is
after he did this to you this is after
and he's like
i'm sorry about what i did out there you
know kind of thing and i'm like
yeah he's like i shouldn't have gone
that hard he's like i hope you know it
was an
accident i don't know how you round
house on accident you know you
you have to go out of your way to i
planted on my foot into the 360 by
accident yeah it accidentally also hit
you i accidentally aimed at your face
hey man i'm sorry i roundhoused you by
accident my accent
don't you start a roundhouse kick from
out of here like yeah i mean you're
putting
everything yeah the arms have to go
first so
halfway through you can pre-meditate a
kick it's a pre-meditated kick
it's not just a kick to this gun no yeah
and it
it it's like god you could have changed
your mind
at this point but you decided to turn
your hips and have your foot follow
and um and then my dad was there and
yeah everything kind of pushed over but
i was scared for a long time i didn't
want to go down that street because that
led me to believe that he lived on that
street and i was just scared man and you
know just
you know what little i learned there was
enough to give me confidence but again
it's like
you know it's like martial arts is great
but it's like to me it's like it only
helps
if you know you have the confidence to
use it in in a situation and
you know i i was always too scared i i
couldn't remember anything but yeah man
that was that was life in long beach man
it's such a story
it's a beautiful your dad is i love the
story
yeah um i want to go back to some early
years too you sent one in about second
grade
let's hear do you know what i'm talking
about second grade your homework
oh my homework man this one this one was
like a
like a like a life-changing one man this
was uh
so so to give you a little uh to give
you some context
i don't know english i don't have
command of
the english language till about fifth
grade right okay so you you grow up in a
household that's just speak spanish
yeah my parents are from mexico you know
sinaloa you know my dad my mom
so the only english you're learning is
from school and
friends you know music you know that
kind of thing so that's
you know and i'm learning as i'm i'm i'm
going but i don't have full command of
it now
i got changed like i i switched school
several times my sec
my second grade year i don't i don't
remember exactly why but i changed
schools quite a bit
but i ended up at bixby elementary
school in long beach right
and um i remember mrs jones you know
teacher just adorable elderly
woman who just had a passion for
teaching loved all the kids you know and
i was just i mean i was a troublemaker
kind of thing
and for a whole almost a whole school
that year i was given homework and i
didn't turn it in
not one let's do it i didn't do it i
didn't bother to do it and tell your
parents about it
well my parents don't know the language
they don't know how to read any of this
stuff so it was just like
you have any homework yup did it all
right
you know and also i was working with my
dad so it's like you know come help me
so my dad wasn't really asking my mom
was the one who's like
don't you have things to do like things
to write i'm like nope did it already
did it on the bus you know and i just
would lie to my parents right
so this is like a whole year what's
happening throughout the year is you're
not turning in these assignments they're
not contacting your parents or trying to
call or anything
i answer the phone i answer the phone
wrong number mrs jones
[Laughter]
oh here tomorrow yeah oh yeah okay thank
you you know me doing a little kid
uh interpretation of an adult voice oh
okay
thank you but boy you know kind of you
know it it wasn't working they're trying
to reach out to my parents it's not
it's it's not happening you know my
parents aren't dropping me off at school
i'm taking a school bus so they don't
see my parents
and every single assignment that i had
so i had like a little closet right with
some toys and i had like
you know a big mess in there so what my
mom did
this is important to the story so my mom
went to top to this
grocery store top value right so she
goes over there and asks for cardboard
boxes so
they give her some banana boxes right
yeah
and they go yeah so they have the big
hole in the middle
right so my mom got about four of those
and i just would put like little
books or you know all my stuff was in a
stack of four boxes and they had a hole
in the middle so i just would throw
stuff on top and it just go
to the bottom and it just kind of filled
up so what i did was in that closet
every assignment that i got i grabbed it
i would crumble it up and i would stick
it in there i was too dumb to know
throw it in the trash get rid of it
before you go home so
so i would stuff it now imagine like how
long is the school year what uh
like ten months nine months say for
seven
months there's seven months worth of
assignments in there whether it was a
packet
whether it was like whatever it was hey
your mom needs to sign this
it's going in the box so it was just why
let me ask you what made you do that did
you not like the work
did you not understand i didn't
understand it very well yeah i mean it's
like
i was a kid you know asking other kids
like how do you spell the i forgot
you know and and then they're like t-h-e
okay that's right i'm just trying to
make sure because i was so embarrassed
yeah i mean it's like i'm having a hard
time
i don't know how to read and write in
spanish i don't know how to do it in
english my dad would say he's like
you're going to end up mute
you don't speak spanish or english and
so i'm trying to figure it out
you know i'm i'm going to school but i'm
attending school i'm not doing any of
the work
i can't understand it really i'm doing
the best i can
and you know you could tell is that the
only class you're doing that with are
you doing work in all your other classes
no this is like second grade so we know
it's the whole day it's a whole day
you know yeah so the whole day is every
class assignment that your
science math it's all getting shoved and
has been animated
everything i for some reason syllabus
it could be like everything drawings
uh you name it like scholastic
uh cat book catalogs they're going in
there bro
they're going in there it like it looked
like a big shoe
if it went home it was going into boxes
it was going in the boxes and it was
just stuffed in there
so i did that for months man and i'm
thinking everything is cool now cut to
one day me in class just chilling
and they always sat me in the front
because again they're like man you're
like you're way behind kind of thing so
they always sat me in the front
and i'm just chilling drawing you know i
was always the kid who doodled a lot so
everything on my desk were just drawings
and stuff so i'm over there drawing
and um i remember i could tell something
was up i don't know what's going on
and um i just happened to look to the
back i remember this so vividly
chalkboard in front of me i'm in the
front of the class there's rows about
like
seven by you know 10 or whatever it's
like kind of a big classroom
and uh i just remember looking back to
the door and um
i see my mom oh [ __ ] and i see an
interpreter
oh no and mrs jones is going you know
you know she's making her way to the
back of the thing now
what stuck out what stuck out to me was
that my mom was in tears
she was sobbing i was like that's not
good
you know what happened so you know if i
break that down it's like
in retrospect it's like my mom had to
take a bus
two buses right to make her to make her
way
to to to bixby went to the school
and i just kept thinking back through
all the embarrassment that i put her
having to go to the office not
understanding
and interpreting interpreter all kinds
of stuff and eventually figure out how
to contact her and tell her your son
hasn't turned in
any so she already knows what the [ __ ]
up yeah or
like at this point i don't know how it
went then you failed as a failure as a
parent
not only am i worried about my kid but
now i'm not doing a good job there's a
lot going on there's a lot going on and
you know
no family is perfect i'll say that you
know uh
you know a lot lots going on at home so
you know that's part of the reason i i
think i fell back i also don't know the
language there's a lot of factors here
right
so i look back and i can tell my mom's
like crying i'm like ooh like
it put this like fear in me right and
i'm just like i don't know what's
happening so
mrs jones let me ask what did you were
you worried maybe you were about to hear
someone died
you weren't were you thinking school you
knew school right away or what
no i didn't know i didn't know i just
knew mom
was crying and you know like i would say
this from a young age i was always like
a caregiver yeah i mean
like i was interpreting i was stuff like
this so it's like
i need to go over there and help mom out
was my instinct but i knew something was
wrong
so mrs jones says hey can you come out
here for a bit and you know
second grade class ooh
and i'm just like you know birds
everybody hi
ma mom are you okay kind of thing and um
so there's like you know interpreters
here mom's here teachers here
and um my mom has two
top value plastic grocery bags that say
thank you thank you thank you repeated
thank you filled with uncrinkled
sheets no she [ __ ] found a banana
boxes bro
i ironed them out bro i just imagined
she opened one box and it was like the
like the snake
the snake coming out of the pringle just
like
two bags man
let's say thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
yeah i never forget the the thank you
repeated the layers i know exactly what
you're talking and um
i just saw two bags but my mom had like
a canvas bag
a bigger one no seven months
of work she had them all she brought
everything she brought everything no way
she uncrinkled every single piece and um
they were sorted out by that time so
what she had in her hand were the
assignments and everything else i
i think was like anything else and they
like it was a long brief and i'm sure
before my mom even went to the classroom
they're like oh this is this they're
trying to tell her what the paperwork is
or
this is the first time they've seen her
since i you know switched
to the school so it's it's bad
it's really bad and my mom is like
crying and she's like
you know i don't know why he does this
you know it's like i don't know why he
lied to me parking lot like
she she
so so so my dad's at work i mean you
know we'll get to that you know later my
dad
no that's coming yeah there you go at
the time there's no cell phone so my
dad's out in the field there's no way of
contacting him he'll get here when he
gets here
and he's gonna get the briefing at the
door and then he'll find me later kind
of thing so
we're still at school and so now they're
telling me it's like
why haven't you done your assignments
it's like you you were telling
um so you were telling your mom that you
were doing them
you know i don't know what i was telling
the teacher to hold her over for seven
months you know i mean
but it wasn't good so now they take me
into another room and there's like
the principal there's like all kind of
faculty i'm at the end of this long
board meeting table just sitting there
swinging my feet
you know just hunched over
feeling bad because my mom is crying in
front of all these teachers it's like
the embarrassment that i'm putting my
mom through is like
[ __ ] man and um so they slide me the
two stacks of just like these like big
column
uh or big uh what do you call a big roll
like with the dotted line in the middle
so you know how to write the letter you
want to talk about
margins you mean not margins margins go
this one
paper yeah paper like writing lines yeah
with the lines that got the dotted line
in the middle
i think it's called ruled rule there it
is so ruled paper for
for a second grader and it's all these
papers and stuff
and uh mrs jones says this is what we're
gonna do
he's like um he's like you're gonna do
every single one of these assignments
and i'm like but it's a lot he's like i
know and we have stuff
to do from now until the end of the year
and you will be doing that as well
so every day you're supposed to turn in
you know i have to chip away at this
stack and i was like
damn it's like i don't know what to do
and then they're like
well we're going to help you there's
going to be after school programs and
you know that kind of thing so
they found the help that i needed you
know to to get these done but
it was very hard for me to go to to
so i would get dropped off at edison
elementary school
there in long beach in you know eastside
long beach so
i would get dropped off there get picked
up in a school bus and driven down to
bixby school now
they had a ymca program so they said
after school you're going to go there
sometimes i didn't want to go there
because i got out so late that i don't
want to walk home at night
or make my mom come get me at night
because it's like it's a whole nother
bag of problems so
so i started doing my assignments my own
way and it was like you know some of it
was like
addition it was like five plus five you
know kind of thing and i just would
write the last number on the bottom
five you know i mean seven plus two two
i'm like man i am
i am blowing through these assignments
i'm stephen hawking in this day
genius you know division i think it was
this easy i just would have done it
yeah i was just like seven plus they're
trying yeah they're trying to teach me a
lesson here you know hang tight guys
you know two times seven like seven you
know
two times three three you know so it was
easy i'm like this is just they're
trying to teach me a lesson kind of
thing
so i go turn all this in and it was like
another problem now they're like
the interpreter's calling you know you
know
my uh my place and they're like yeah
your son is
thinks this is a joke and they're like
why
he's like he's just writing whatever on
the assignments he's not really doing
them is he going to the
you know edison uh to get help he's like
yeah
so now they reach out to edison he's
like what is jesus doing
while he's there well actually he's
playing a lot of chess over there you
know it's like i'm just
playing chess i'm just not doing what
i'm supposed to again because i don't
have the direction
and um long story short i had to do all
those assignments but
it really to this day or still messes
with me to know that i put my mom to
something like that but it
you know i would say it wasn't my fault
but it was my fault i didn't take
responsibility at that time to really
ask for help or do those things i was
just you know
the phrase fish out of water i was i was
exactly that man and
you know i i definitely never wanted to
put my parents in that situation again
which
of course i did i was a kid you know and
um but yeah man that one right there
really sticks with you does your mom
ever bring it up
oh yeah she does huh yes cause like um
you know even now like like i have like
a little bin in my room and i
crumble up like i'm writing stuff or
jokes and i throw it in there it's like
is that homework assignments i'm like oh
you're not living the girl mom yeah yeah
so it stuck with her too
did she was she's super proud at
graduation and everything like when you
all got said and done
you you know what's funny like i'm i'm
the first in my family
to to go to school period kind of thing
so i i remember like
kindergarten being a big deal like
graduation it was a big deal it was
huge like all alfred
brought out the good wranglers yeah man
you put on the wrangler jeans and a
church wrangler oh my goodness
oh yeah kindergarten
yeah they uh kindergarten in fifth grade
by the time i got to fifth grade
you know it's like and i and i graduated
like you know it's
and to me to like to show that
improvement from second grade
doing stuff like that to having command
of the language and you know being able
to participate a little more
my grades were really terrible uh
the big shift happened around middle
school for me and you know my parents
again there was a lot of crying that my
mom did it's like why don't you do your
work why don't you like
like pay attention in school and i'm
like well there's more to it than that
my you know kind of thing but
um you know i i eventually i did turn
around so yeah my parents were
were very proud that i you know
graduated you know school along the way
and went to college and all that good
stuff so
you did where'd you go uh cal state
dominguez okay yeah man
and you got your degree yeah business
degree marketing so you went from you're
the only person in your family ever go
to school and you went all the way and
got the uh
yeah my extended degree yeah like my dad
never went to sleep
yeah my you know my dad never went to
school my mom
had very little schooling um so it's
like you know it was a big deal it was a
big deal for us to
you know school school was a big deal
and i would have gone on further but you
know
in comedy you know comedy came around
and that's what i wanted to
get my phd and kind of thing so that's
awesome dude let's take a quick break
and tell you about our first sponsor
expressvpn
now going on the internet without a vpn
is like
i say it every week it's like going to
the bathroom with the door open why are
you doing that some of you do it don't
do that
don't do it it's not good for anybody
it's not good for anybody all right
internet service providers like comcast
or verizon they know
every single website that you visit and
then isps can sell this information to
ag companies and tech giants
who then use your data to target you
okay expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet
so people can't watch what you're doing
online
you can just simply fire up the app you
click one button
one it's rated number one by cnet wired
the verge it works on your phones
your tablets your laptops even works on
your routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi
can be protected all right what i like
most about expressvpn is no matter where
i am
i can watch whatever i want with privacy
okay i can go in another city
watch ball games over there i can watch
whatever i want you can go to
uh switch it for uk japan different
countries
okay so secure your online activity by
visiting expressvpn.com
honeydew today that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash honeydew and you can get
an extra three months for free
expressvpn.com honeydew
our next sponsor is stamps.com are you
still going to the post office are you
still paying full price for postage
well thanks to stamps.com you don't have
to anymore you can mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters
you can ship packages and you can pay
less a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
more shout out to ups baltimore hub
primary one joe avenue
all right stamps.com brings the services
of the u.s postal service and ups right
to your computer it is a must-have
for any business whether you're a small
office sending invoices
if you're a side hustle over there doing
your etsy shop shipping out orders
or you're just navigating this hybrid
work life stamps.com
can handle it all with ease no wonder
over 1 million businesses
choose stamps.com for their mailing and
their shipping i've used it for years
back in the craft these days
i would ship all our shirts and stuff
using stamps.com it's easy it's simple
you just simply use your computer to
print official us postage 24
7 for any letter any package any class
of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready you just schedule a pickup or
you drop it off it's that simple with
stamps.com you get discounts up to 40
percent off post office rates
and up to 66 percent off of ups shipping
rates
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive postage
meters
stop wasting time going to the post
office go to stamps.com
instead there's no risk and with my
promo code honeydew
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in honeydew
that's stamps.com promo code honeydew
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
now let's get back to the do i want to
um
jump around to a story down here about
the radio stations and i'm
i'm dying to hear this that's perfect
because it's around college
college i'm going to cal state dominguez
hills right and
uh yeah i interned at a radio station in
college too did you interned you worked
there
no i interned it was part of a radio
program
um so cal state dominguez hills had a
radio program that
very little people signed up for they
had like an actual studio you had the
sound board and
you know they had the actual system that
most radio stations would use you know
you put the music in then you had your
breaks and like hey you know welcome
back
um so i got to do that it was really
cool and one of the things i wanted to
do
because at the time i'm already like i
want to do comedy
and i know that comedians you know
oftentimes were on the radio
and you know they got to be on air so
i'm like this is something comedians do
so i'm like
i think i have to do that you know so
that was the whole thing behind me
taking that
you know radio course and then they said
you can work at a radio station and
we'll give you college credit
i said man you're speaking my language
so i found a radio station i'm not going
to say what radio station it was
and which actually is no longer around
they've is it am
or was it fm fm fm and uh so i go over
there
and you know i email back and forth and
they say hey come on down
you know bring the paper we'll sign you
off for some credit um
so i'm like i don't have the paperwork
yet but you know this is something i
have the syllabus that kind of thing
they said all right well once you
you know we'll get you familiar with
everything and so i go i'm living the
dream i'm
taking out the binders with all the
promotions i'm
you know uh doing uh printing out copy
uh news stories man i'm on top of the
world yeah i mean it's like it feels
good
and most of my time was spent in the
other room
answering phones hey caller number one
call number two
hey i want to hear you know such and
such all right man hey what's your name
what's your age
where you calling us from so we were you
know you know getting all these
statistics of of the people calling in
and um and yeah i'm writing down
song requests that never got played the
songs usually were on rotation
you know kind of thing and uh so you
know so i'm doing that i'm i'm really
enjoying it man i'm i'm like this this
feels right
um i'm getting along with the honor dj's
i'm even staying longer than i should
because now i'm
helping the other dj set out his stuff
so they can
like have a few minutes to themselves
and i'm you know doing all the tedious
stuff so
i'm back there i'm answering the phones
and i would talk to the people
who would call in right it would be good
conversation
so at the time they were giving away
like a like a family four pack
a family far back of like to disneyland
and people would light up and they were
like
that's a lot of money yeah so you know
they would give you the thing and
uh which i should say i'm i'm going to
stop there radio is a big part of my
like upbringing like my mom will listen
to the radio
all the time my dad when i would go work
with him what would she listen to
all spanish stuff you know and yeah yeah
my dad too
actually when i uh when i didn't help
you learn it anymore
listening to music all day like that uh
yeah i could talk i i could talk spanish
yeah i mean
you know i could that was my first
language i just couldn't read it or
write it kind of thing
and uh so when i i filmed my my my
my hour special pyolin who's a big radio
personality here
in uh los angeles came to the taping my
dad
i mean lost it baby you see my dad
fixing his hair
he's fixing his i should have said he
was coming out
you should have said he was coming i
would have worn a better suit you know
i would have got the good rag and my mom
was like yeah yeah my
my mom was like what so i had an
assignment so i remember
uh pulls up he was with his son so he
pulls up and
he's in this truck and he's like hey i'm
gonna go park
i'll be right over there my dad goes
over there and the
the truck windows open and he like
sticks his hand and he's like hey it's a
pleasure to meet you i'm like that would
you get over here
and he's just excited so he parked and
and my parents were about to leave
because
this was now the second uh uh the second
show that night
i did two and two that night um
so they already saw the first show
they're about to leave the uber's
waiting for us
and he's like i don't know he was going
to come i'm going to stick around for a
little bit i'm like oh
you guys so he comes over and you know
they got to say hi
and just my dad just it it meant the
world that you know if you're leaning
the sun was there and my parents ended
up
you know going home but that's what
radio means to us
my mom one time won a blender on a radio
station
and it was a big deal it was a t-shirt a
blender and a keychain and
uh she called my my cousin who's my
godfather and it was like hey can you
give us a ride to hollywood
because we have to go to hollywood to
pick up this blender he's like sure
and that was the first time i ever went
to to hollywood we were walking on
hollywood boulevard we're
um the handprints by the theater you
know it's like
uh filled with human feces
yeah it was it was pretty gnarly but
they had you know cantinflas you know
you know had his
and you know along with other mexican
you know
singers or actors that kind of thing so
it was a big deal we got the blender
and so can i share can i tell you
already look i've told this on the
show before but i'm going to tell you
this story because this is yeah please
i'm only this is a radio story for you
right so
um back in the day we drove this
volkswagen beetle right we called it the
pants pocket it was it was originally
red
but my parents got it painted blue for
free
because the phone book was doing
um this advertising deal where
if you got your car painted blue and you
put
their logo all over the car for i don't
know what it was maybe a year
they then peel the stickers off at the
end of the year of free advertising and
boom you got a free paint job
okay that was the deal so we get this
red beetle now painted blue
and it's got go by the book went back
when they had the fingers they let your
fingers do the wall yeah yeah so that's
all over our [ __ ] car right
and then they peeled the thing off you
could totally see the silhouette of
the stickers all this [ __ ] it was just a
shitty job so we drive in this car
and my mom listens to country music back
in the day and the station's 93 wpoc
right well they're doing this [ __ ]
competition where they're giving away
now remember i'm older than you so this
is in the 80s i'm probably
10 11. okay and we all play sports i
have two brothers we're all play sports
we're all good
they're doing this competition they're
giving away a dodge chrysler laser
brand new car okay 93 people
i don't know what you had to do call in
or whatever well my mother is one of the
93
and she has an opportunity to win this
car and what you have to do is you got
to go to the
uh inner harbor in baltimore and in the
like little courtyard area they had they
had the dot
they had a dodge chrysler laser and you
had to stand back
i don't know what it was 93 feet i don't
even know what the hell it was
but you had to throw a football through
the window the driver's window if you
did
you won the [ __ ] car okay so the
rules were 93 people were going to go
if no one does it through the first pass
we go again
until everybody gets a turn and someone
wins this car right this night
somebody's getting in the car okay we're
in baltimore city
someone's winning the car for sure and i
say all the time there's this one young
dude
[ __ ] looking like johnny you over
here who doesn't stop
throwing he's practicing he's practicing
my mom's deep
somewhere i want i feel like in the deep
80s
okay but he's behind us and i'm like
[ __ ]
at least we got a shot to get one in
before [ __ ] johnny you over here
my mom doesn't have [ __ ] okay okay my
mom didn't bother to talk to us
my mom didn't do anything i said you
even [ __ ] practice haha yeah i had
some friends at work i'm like friends
my mom was we were not none of us were
close anyway but we're
stuck with her we go my mother gets the
ball and we're like please god
let us get us out of this [ __ ]
volkswagen like we're all there's five
of us crammed in this [ __ ]
she threw this [ __ ] ball and it
starts off this thing died not even
halfway there
ah it just [ __ ] out and skirted over
there we were like god damn it
so now we gotta hope that everyone
misses so we get another chance into 93
to go again
and two or three throws later johnny you
comes up
right in the goddamn window oh you know
what he does he goes right over the side
and he keeps on throwing because there's
other people after him
just in case he's got to go one-on-one
with somebody and he didn't and that
[ __ ] won the car
whoa won the car yeah hilarious just
seeing the ball die mid-air just like a
lead [ __ ] balloon bro
nothing not just a horrible just a
horrible thing there's something very
special about like radio man it's just
like
you know people really get like like
this is a big part of their day they
listen to it at work they on the way to
work
a chance to win some good money
sometimes a car that's a [ __ ] car
back then that was a nice car yeah right
yeah it's like you can win something you
can win
money prizes a car and
yeah man so what happened so what are
you guys doing there so we're doing a
family four pack
of disney tickets and people are calling
up and you know we would give them away
and it was great i would answer it's
like it's like 500 bucks to get four
people in the distance that's huge and
this is years ago yeah i mean so it was
like really expensive
and um but in that promotion they're
like
you can win 500 bucks
if you call when you hear
this song they'll play so in addition to
the disneyland you're getting 500 on top
of it yeah
they would only play that song or
like once or twice it was like twice in
in
in one day you would get 500 bucks a
thousand dollars a day
you know only two chances you got to be
listening but so
so it goes down and um you know i'm
giving away the family four pack
you know you know i call you know i i
call the honor dj through the little uh
one-way
uh speaker thing and i say hey you know
i have the winner great
they play the song and i'm like oh dang
that's
you know and then they're like we just
played this song the phone lines are
gonna you know be
you know crazy and we're gonna you know
pick the caller they said the number of
the caller
so my job was to dump all the calls and
and count by tens
10 20 30. now you're you know you're
going down to the number
i didn't know that i was not supposed to
pick the winner
for the 500 bucks right they were gonna
do it
over there so i was dumping but then i
was like one two three whatever like
let's say it was caller number
67. so i dumped you know five times
on number six and one two three four
five you know
and i would go color number one no color
number two
and they were like hello like did i get
it did i get it
i'm like i have some good news for you
hang tight
right and then i'm listening to the
radio i have a little radio in my office
and i hear
and the winner of the 500 is you know
joe schmoe you know whoever it was like
oh my god and i'm like
i got the winner right here on hold i
got the winner right here he's he's
holding
i'm like oh man this is not going to go
well
and i click on and i click on the thing
and i'm like
hello you there yeah right here did i
win like like
hold tight i'm like [ __ ] he's still
there what do i do
and there's a delay right so it's like
by this point he knows
he's not the winner even though i told
him he's like i have good news a
whole time he doesn't have a chance to
call back it's bad i'm sweating bricks
you haven't told anybody yet no just you
and him
sitting there me with my face in my lap
going what did i just do
i'm gonna get fired from a job that i'm
not being paid for yeah
that means the world to me right now
i'm not gonna get my three college
credits for this yummy
you know yes exactly so it's like
i'm i don't know what to do i'm [ __ ]
bricks i'm like man now what
and um so i go in the studio and they're
like
yeah you know uh here's the winner and
i'm i'm just
pale sweating she she slides me the info
first name last name now i got to get
the rest of the information address
bubba i'm filling out the form
hey congratulations like oh my god i got
the 500 bucks yeah uh congratulations
you know and i know in the back of my
mind
i got my homie on hold still so i'm
filling out the thing i said all right
congratulations you can pick up the
prize on
on you know such day bring your id so
they can verify that you're the winner
of it blah blah
and um and and the on-air host could
tell that something's wrong it's like
you're all right
yeah yeah no i'm all right and then i'm
like i'm gonna go answer phones they're
like all right
so i go back there and i answer i'm like
hey man how's it going he's like
he's quiet man i could hear dead air
um you didn't win the thing i don't know
if you were listening and
i'll never forget he goes nawfu
nah nah nah man
i heard his feelings so bad and i'm just
like i'm really sorry now i'm full
i want i i i won the 500 so like
nah man listen there was a mistake no no
not fool
i'm like thanks for calling and uh good
luck next time
i hit the dump button i was like that's
it
i get one call on the line one light's
blinking
hello you know i i do my little spiel
i won the money fool he's calling back
i'm i'm
this is like a horror story scared now
oh yes
and he's he's staying away like those
those those boxers yeah i i didn't wear
him ever again
i love that he's being super quiet nah
fool
i'll never forget that's way more of a
mind [ __ ] than somebody screaming you'd
be like whatever i've heard people yell
whispering it and composure like that
and then he would listen to me it sounds
like he's cleaning his gun on the other
end you know
just and and and i'm trying to like you
know plead my case here i'm like listen
i only answer phones you know they they
pick the grand prize
you know in booth like in in in the main
studio
i just you know screened the calls and
i'm like explaining my job title to the
guy i'm like so nervous
and you know there was a mistake and i
apologize but you can you know call in
again you have a chance to win
500 bucks tomorrow you know you you have
two chances to win i'm
now saying the spiel and um so yeah
no fool
oh man so and and he would kept
he kept calling in and um it just ruined
my whole day
or well well that we're still talking
about that now it's just that night he's
coming he keeps calling
and it just ruined my day and i'm
supposed to stay longer now because i
made friends with the
second on-air dj so it's like they're
like hey man are you all right yeah i
know i'm all right
and then he's like uh can we told
anybody no no
cause that would be the last thing this
dude didn't call it anybody else at the
station or no he's calling the same line
the
you know the guy picking up and um so
eventually i'm like he's gonna have to
talk to somebody and i said look
i pick up the thing and he's awful he's
there
i said look man i messed up i'm sorry
i work i work here i answer the phones
let me talk to some people and see what
we can do if we can get you a
consolation prize
novel and um you know
i i'll make this right give me a call
tomorrow
he just hung up i was like [ __ ] and i'm
like leaving the building looking over
my shoulder i'm like he's
he's sitting on the hood of my car yeah
yeah swinging his feet going
hey fool you know i mean and um i'm
scared
i go home i'm just like i can't even
sleep that night i feel so bad
that this guy is supposed to get the 500
and he you know he didn't get him so i
go
i come to work dreading it and um
the do starts calling in and um
so now i'm just dumping the call i'm
dumping the call like hello and i can
i knew it was him i would dump the call
now i have to go in studio
they answer one of the calls in there
and he explains everything to me i know
so now i get a call from like the the
radio like the manager guy he's like hey
can i speak with you like yeah yeah
and he's like you can't do this to
people it's like if they want something
it's like you know we could get
sued it's 500 bucks so he's like we have
to find a way to
you know figure out you know make him
win something and it's just like i'm i'm
really sorry he's like what are you
doing back there i'm like
i thought i was supposed to dump the
callers and get to this one it was
really bad like
like he's like bosses are coming down on
me this guy keeps calling
so he he not only kept calling yeah
of course he so he's been calling so now
they're annoyed and they're sweating
like i am because
all they're hearing this
the whole station's scared the whole
station is scared
from this guy i would have just done
everybody pony up some money here let's
see if we can get this guy
and and and the station i'll give props
to the station they made right by him
they did give him five on her i don't
know what they gave him but he was
quite happy i just made sure i wasn't
there the day he came to pick up the
prize
[ __ ] dude and um i i never told him my
name or anything i was just like very
scared and i still think about that guys
like man
like however long it took for him to get
500 bucks like man he worked for those
500 bucks
that was not free like he worked for
that a lot but anyway that's my little
uh radio story
um i want to get this story in before we
have to get out of here but tell me
about mexico city
oh mexico city man loved it loved mexico
city so i went out there to do some
shows
i was performing you know stand up out
there in some in spanish and
when how long ago uh no this is like few
years ago
now um so like about four years ago
right so i'm out there doing
shows and uh my homie demar randy shout
out to more randy uh he went out there
with me
so we're out there we're having a good
time and you know he doesn't speak
spanish but he's like
you know the shows that they would do
out there in mexico city they would do
them in english sometimes and i'm like
you know we'll get you some stage time
and he performed the comics know english
so
you know we got him some stage time and
you know i have you know
some stage time too we're not doing like
big shows it's just kind of like
doing a run of shows right and we're
having a good time now
i have a huge addiction to pastries
muffins
pandul it's pretty bad where's that come
from
did your mom make them back in the day
or i used to go to bakeries as a kid and
just like
cash out on whatever my dad would give
me what was your go to
oh conchas empanadas uh there was this
uh
one called royos which was like a so it
doesn't have to be sweet just
any kind of paper anything i like
cupcakes i
yeah it's like i'm i'm i got really
addicted to cupcakes muffins
remember how costco used to have like
the box with all the muffins yeah yeah
and before it was all chocolate all
poppy seed all this
now they give you the variety pack i
used to buy the chocolate box
i could probably kill it in two sittings
like like i put them in a bowl of milk
just pour like it was cereal real
problem i mean
and um so i have this like huge
addiction to like
sweets sweet bread in particular since i
was a kid
and um so we're in mexico city and they
got bakeries right in front of the
airbnb
where i'm staying so every day for a
week i'm going out there i'm loving it
twice a day you know a cup of coffee
some champurrado
i mean whatever it is and i'm killing
peace i'm taking pieces of bread to the
dome like
killing it and by like the fourth day
you know i make friends with the baker
and i'm you know telling them it's like
man you got some good stuff here man
and he's oh man he's like are you new in
town i said i'm just visiting but you
know kind of
i'm just blown away by your bread you
know kind of thing so
before we leave i tell damara i said hey
i got to take
i got to take some of this bread back
home yeah i was like what are you going
to
do
from mexico city yeah some of this fresh
bread
some fresh bread and uh he's like
he's like it's it's not gonna get there
nice
you know i mean it's like you have to
carry it it's gonna be sawdust when you
get there
i'm like nah so i'm kind of like
thinking like my mind's turning
[Laughter]
now for it's my bread
so so we go to this uh
uh target equivalent right and um i'm
shopping for backpacks
so i'm looking for the biggest backpack
i can find so i go in there and i buy
some
some backpacks two backpacks because i
had some more stuff i wanted to take
back but i got the big one and i asked
for extra
plastic bags and i lined the inside of
this backpack
i'm about to fill it up with with bread
so we go the last day right
because we're flying out the next day in
the morning so i go into the bakery and
i throw the backpack on the counter
and um the baker looks at me and throws
my backpack on the
on on the ground i'm like why'd you do
that
he said you want to rob me is that what
it is i said no no i've been coming here
all week like
why would i rob you of all people you
know i mean it's like uh
i'm like i'm gonna take some bread and
and then uh
he's like i i thought you had a gun in
there or something i'm like no no not at
all
and it was kind of a weird thing and and
so i said i'm going to get a bunch of
bread i'm leaving this bag here just so
you know i'm not stealing anything
but i'm going to get a bunch of bread so
i take 30 us dollars worth of
of mexican bread damar got a tray
demar got a tray i got a tray and we
already got a tray on the counter full
of bread
and i'm just like getting pieces
putting up yeah i mean so
listen i thought i liked bread no you
[ __ ]
love it you do not like bread i like
bread bro
i'm hearing chopin music playing in my
head
yeah i mean yeah and then you know
classical music i'm just like i'm
loading it up man i
i i can't get enough of it and uh
so we got three three trays right
and uh demar is looking at me he's like
i don't know bro
this is going to look mad suspicious i
said hear me out man we're going to get
this bread there
right so we borrow the bread they give
us he
uh he didn't put him in the backpack he
put him in brown paper bags and he's
like you do it at
you know at home i'm not doing it here
so we take it i go back to the airbnb
and i'm like carefully placing all the
pieces of bread in there paul bordone is
one of my favorites so i'm
i'm leaving those for the top because
it's like almost like shortbread cookie
so i'm leaving those for the top the
pencil department in the backpack you
know i'm putting like
like a smaller like cookie type stuff in
there
i pack it out it's a big backpack it
looks suspicious as [ __ ]
now we got to go to the airport so we're
going out of uh we're flying back to l.a
out of benito juarez
airport in mexico city so
and and this is early this is like five
in the morning so we're outside of the
airport
just chilling on like 3 30 in the
morning 4 a.m
and we're just chilling right me and
damar
and um so now it's time to go and
like going through customs they start
sweating tomorrow
and they're like you need this paper to
get back in
he's like i don't have it i'm like did
you did you lose it it's like that paper
you fill out like when you go to
montreal or you know stuff like that
save it you got to save it the whole
time
and they're giving us a hard time and
then he's like
it's either 500 bucks or you find the
thing
or you stay here until like i got 1500
worth of bread right here
i'll give you a third let me put
something together for you man you like
bread
how do y'all feel about this kind of
bread hear me out
hear me out excuse me can i get your
attention please you'd be the only agent
that would be like i got you down here
down here get on the intercom is it this
is
we got one for you bring it do you got
pandas there yeah come on down here
and the intercom does this work here
y'all like pandulse
and sure enough i end up with the guy in
customs that goes
nafu that's who i get
that's who i get right so now we're
looking for this thing our
luggage hold on give me just yeah so i'm
how overstuffed is your like is it
like if you turn are you hitting people
with your backpack like how far off your
back let me tell you this
let me tell you have you seen those
office chairs they're like
a big like a bouncy ball with the handle
like kids haven't like
yeah imagine that i put that in a
backpack
yeah it looked like i got kirby in the
backpack
like i'm kidnapping kirby
so i got the backpack and they're like
you know it was stuffed because
the the backpack straps weren't down
here it was just like this
tight up under like i just
deployed a parachute oh my god
so both you get pulled we're there yeah
we're both pulled our luggage are out
we're trying to find for this
this little piece of paper it's it's
getting down to the wire so we got to
make this
flight and we still have to go to
customs and we still got to go to the
next checkpoint
and he finds it and the guy's like all
right now you guys could go
so they're not sweating you about the
bread they're just like [ __ ] that you we
want the paper
not food not yet yeah so it's about it
it's about to go down because they got
an eye on us you know it's like hey
you've been radioed ahead about oh yeah
yeah i can hear
old rusty cameras at benito juarez
airport
yeah yeah so it's like it
all all all eyes on us from the
from the flight people from from the
airline to security
and um it just feels weird we're walking
down the airport
we get to customs now we got to take
everything off and put them in the
conveyor belt so i put the thing demar
goes first and he's already over there
packing his stuff trying to you know
put on his jacket backpack i'm walking
through
and senor
over here yeah yeah for sure so i i go
over there and they got this
kirby backpack big old thing like this
and they're like
what's in the bag like bread
he's like come over here so now they're
walking this
this bread bag they're radioing people
now i have
i i have two like officers i i guess one
of them has a dog
right and the dog's at attention he's
not he's like mad dogging me
uh can i answer a question yeah you
haven't thought
one moment that this guy thinking
possibly that
you could have robbed him could have put
anything in this [ __ ] bread to [ __ ]
you all customs
not until this moment
i watched that [ __ ] international
lock up
and they do they'll they'll so [ __ ] see
you gave the guy your backpack
and i've seen them take stuff and sew it
inside the backpack and he didn't have
enough time to go into
i mean so yeah i did not think of that
i'm i'm
i'm blind so this is an absurd amount of
bread that no one
has probably ever seen in the history of
their job so they it's worth of taking a
look
i'm i'm blinded by my love of bread i'm
not thinking
rationally that's when you know you have
a problem when you're not thinking
rationally
and when they call for backup for for
your body i'm still not thinking
anything i'm just like
what it's bread yeah it's a lot okay
then what
so you know they pulled me over you know
off to the side
and then like um so what's in the bag
i'm like well brett
he's like do you have anything in in
here that's illegal i'm so calm as a
whistle yeah i'm chilling
i said nah i don't have anything he's
like i'm like didn't y'all
just look at it through the x-ray
there's nothing in there it's just
literally bread and a backpack that's
all it is
they're like all right he's like we're
gonna have to open it i'm like yeah feel
free
so they open it and the sweet buttery
taste
i love a thousand
the wrath of a thousand buttery uh
mexican fanduel says starts to fill
benito juarez airport
what are they doing the dog that the
officer has
you could tell
you got the bondusa yeah i mean he's
salivating
red hat yes he says
he's looking at the office they're like
what are we supposed to do about this
i don't know that i could uh do my job
effectively right now
they've never thrown me this training
you might have ruined it thong you might
have ruined it
he might be all like leave or something
and it was warm from having this
backpack on my back
so any piece of fondue
that was up against my back is nice and
warm steamy
you got [ __ ] red marks on your back
and [ __ ]
i got the imprint of a concha on my back
i mean
i look like diabetes that's how much
fondue i had
if diabetes was a person it was me
and um so now i got this massive amount
of bread out in the open
and everyone's just like everyone just
crosses their arms like
and i guess now after you saying that
everyone's like
we know how this plays out but i was
just still like so one of the
this is what broke my heart one of the
people uh working the thing
not not an officer but one of the uh
people working
uh customs i guess a a customs officer
goes i'm gonna have to pat the bread to
make sure that there's anything in it
i'm like but you just
put it through the x-ray machine shrugs
his shoulders
goes over there and starts pressing on
the bread and i just see the top part
oh just starts cracking
he's so he's breaking your bread and
your heart
bro bro
bro it's breaking my heart man it's
he he he starts going piece by piece and
he's like breaking it he's breaking the
bread
and whatever pieces of bread doesn't
break it's all smushy puts them off to
the side
they're going piece by piece bro and
demar was like
i look over tomorrow he's just shaking
his head like
like i told you kind of thing i was like
man so they go through the whole thing
they ruin
everything they ruin everything and um
and then they're like all right yeah we
didn't find anything have a good flight
now i got now you got a bag full of
sawdust
imagine it at home though did you get it
home i put everything
great thank you for asking that because
one of them said
you can throw it away right here i said
i'm not throwing it away
i grabbed it and i'm like those bins
where you put your wallet
and like the stuff yeah so i grab it i
just put the corner down to open the
backpack and i'm like shaking all the
stuff in there and i zipped it up and
i'm sitting there with now
what looks like a normal backpack
full of sawdust and tomorrow's like
are you going to eat that i'm like yeah
yeah i'm going to eat that
and i remember there like being on the
plane and i'd open it up and just sneak
like
i would like pack it like it was chewing
tobacco
yeah bro yeah pack it in nice and tight
and just killing it right up with it and
i got it
last thing i'll say i got home and my
dad was like
what the hell is this i'm like and i
explained the whole thing to him it's
like can you still brighten that throw
it away i said i ain't throwing away
so i had a like like a like two weeks
worth of bread that i would just go over
there and just
chew into back pinch and just give me a
little i love it dude
but yeah that's my little mexican bread
story in mexico city all right
now we're at the end of this here we've
talked about what we've talked about
what advice would you give to your 16
year old self i'll be honest the
the the main piece of advice i would
give my younger
self 16 year old self is
everything that you got in trouble for
like
doodling um you know
being disruptive to a certain extent
like
doodling all the writing all the all
that stuff
like pay attention to that because
that's gonna pay the bills one day
all the creative stuff and you know
sometimes i do understand listening to
people because you know they've lived
life and they
they can give you a piece of advice of
like you know go to school
do this it's like i'm i'm happy that i
listen to all those things but
prioritize what you want to do in life
just as much as
everything else that your parents tell
you go to school go to college
do this prioritize that too because
that's a big part of it and i wish i
would have
i would have pursued you know some of
these things a lot more and you know
i'm a comic now so it's like you know
i'm i'm so happy that i
that i came around to it you know it's
like i was able to figure it out
and um uh advice
yeah be patient i love it please
uh promote again everything you'd like
wait a minute um you uh instagram
at jesustrack on the number one twitter
at jesus trejo or jesus.com
for upcoming shows um yeah i got some
stuff coming up so
i don't have any exact dates right now
but i'll be posting
in the coming weeks hope to see you at a
show thank you for being awesome and for
the opportunity it's great to see you
man you too brother thank you so much
uh for coming on for real it was a lot
of fun thank you and uh
thank you all as well um brian
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you